the president of the united states and
dr biden
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
please
thank you
thank you
i have to catch my breath after that
thank you and it's my pleasure to
welcome all of you so many good friends
and family
to the white house and we're pleased to
welcome the t-shock of ireland meehaw
martin and his wife mary as well as the
irish delegation to washington d.c
[Applause]
so to love joe biden is to know ireland
so picture me on our first few dates
dressed in bell bottoms and a peasant
shirt
i wore my hair down to the middle of my
waist and at the time so did most of the
man i dated
and then there was this senator handsome
and buttoned up in his suit and loafers
casually quoting yates
it was the last thing i expected
but in the end he won me over
it doesn't matter when joe's ancestors
left
a piece of that island was passed down
to each generation
in memories and stories and family lore
how close like a precious gem an emerald
heart that shines like the light after a
storm
it's a loyalty that knows family
means forever
of faith tried and tested by famine and
war
and optimism brave enough to leave the
life you know behind
and find what's waiting on distant
shores
he's not alone of course
like so many generations of immigrants
irish americans brought the best of
their home with them on wind and
steamship so many years ago
ridiculed and despised
they found new ways to create traditions
while never letting go of the legacies
that made them
enriching our country along the way
so it's fitting
that we honor that heritage
by celebrating saint patrick
a man who brought a faith to ireland
enriching it too
there's always been a divine spark in
the open arms of welcome
yes
i got to know ireland through the eyes
of joe biden
on st patrick's day all americans no
matter their background
fall in love with it too
we reach for a legacy buried deep inside
of us
or gifted second hand
we celebrate a spirit that defies
struggle
we recognize the rich tapestry of our
history
threads
of clover green amid the red
white and blue happy st patrick's day
[Applause]
well happy st patrick's everyone
it's great to see you all here and uh
last year because of the pandemic the
taoiseach and i had a hold our
meeting virtually
how you doing pal
we got all the irish here today
this is the first year we've had to make
some last-minute adjustments as well
sadly the taoiseach and miss martin are
not able to join us today but
they both sent their
love and their messages for this
occasion and i spoke with the t-shirt at
length this morning
and we had a virtual meeting bilateral
meeting he's feeling well
and i share his disappointment that we
weren't able to have our meetings in
person as we had planned
this year marks the 70th year of ireland
sending shamrocks to the white house
and to celebrate the friendship between
our nations and the bond the bond that
has been strengthened by generations of
irish americans
apparently uh president truman was away
when the irish ambassador dropped off
the first bowl of shamrocks and
that's why i just removed his bus from
my office
that's a joke
i didn't do that didn't do that
i'm sure he would have been there had he
known
a virtual reading back then was sort of
out of the question
but by the next year president
eisenhower was able to accept in person
a joyful tradition was born at that
moment when he accepted everyone here
today
welcome back to the white house so nice
to be able to have you all back inside
the way
[Applause]
so many friends here so many friends are
irish irish americans
americans who wish they're irish
as my grandfather used to our
grandfather my sister valerie's here my
daughter ashley's here my brother-in-law
my brother my other sister-in-law my
niece we're all here but uh i'm probably
the only one no not to remember my
grandfather ambrose finnegan as well as
you might expect someone when they were
that age
and he used to have an expression he
said if you're lucky enough to be irish
you're lucky enough
[Applause]
there's a lot of proud irish american
members of my administration
but there's one person here i want to
recognize in particular in my
administration my secretary of labor i'd
understand him if he spoke better if he
spoke gaelic instead of boston
where where are we marty walsh
there you are martin
[Applause]
marty wall
from galway
transfers from the galway i tell you
what i
i don't know i like i said if you spoke
gaelic i didn't understand it better
than yeah the cowboy and all that look
proud son of two irish immigrants to
this country who found their way
in america and to america and dream
through their union membership and
all the work that this man did to
promote the union movement
and all the members of the house and
senator here you have to hear me again a
lot of you i apologize
and
i look at one irishman bobby casey uh
over here he's from
from the same hometown scranton
pennsylvania right bobby
[Applause]
i knew bobby's dad well he was a hell of
a guy and
we lived literally
four five city blocks apart from one
another the problem is that i'm older
than bobby as his father was than me so
we're right in the middle there but
the best thing bobby has going for him
is a magnificent wife and his mother is
a saint god lover
and tell mom i said hi for real
look uh our new ambassador at ireland
can't be with us today but i'm very
pleased that claire cronin from boston
uh has officially begun her work in
dublin i just got off a a
video with her on the phone and she was
uh mildly tearful she wanted to be here
with everyone but i wish you all going
to get to meet her she's really quite a
person
and unusual in washington uh as i'm
usually referred to as jill biden's
husband
which i'm proud of but today i'm
catherine eugenia finnegan's biden's son
that's who i am
and uh
jimmy val and i we come by our love for
ireland honestly it's been more than 165
years since our great great grandparents
left county mayo and county loud aboard
the coffin shipped across the atlantic
now i want to ask my relatives from
county laos to stand up three come on
stand up guys
[Applause]
now we see this guy here in the
[Applause]
he's end the single most famous rugby
player in all of ireland and he scored
the winning goal against the all blacks
when he gave him chicago
and he's my cousin
good to have you man
good to have you
and the bluets and the finnegans uh
eventually settled in scranton
pennsylvania um where my grandparents uh
where my my parents met and married and
that that's where my mom katherine
junior finnegan was born and later as i
said met joseph robinette biden the
senior
his saving grace was his mother was a
hannah
his mother's side they had a hannah fee
from galway that saved him in the family
that saved him up in scranton
being irish and my mother always told me
is about family it's about faith and
it's about courage
mom used to have an expression my
brother and sister will remember she
said courage is the greatest of all
virtues because without it you could not
love with abandon
courage is the greatest of all virtues
because without it you could not love
with abandon
growing up an irish american gave me a
pride that spoke both to both continents
the heart and soul that
drew it from old and new
and uh the conviction that everyone
everyone is deserving and being treated
with dignity i was mentioning today i
think it's fair to say i can't prove
this but i think it's fair to say i've
never heard
the word dignity
used as much that i have among the irish
because the deprivation of the beating
treatment with dignity is understood
dignity one of my great uncles
wrote from i wrote from the united
states after he made it to america
one of those letters they used to call
america letters
back to his loved ones in ireland
yearning for home he wrote
if there was a road made of furs
furs is a yellow flower with thorns in
it
there's a road he said if there was a
road made of furs in america from
america to ireland i'd walk it in my
bare feet
i'd walk into my bare feet
our great grandfather edward francis
blewett
was only the second catholic ever
elected to the state senate we talked
about this gov in the state of
pennsylvania
the first one was in the early 1880s and
but i think he was uh he was he was the
second
and uh he was elected my name was
lexoffs he had a
my great-grandfather was had an injury
from lafayette college
and he had the heart of an irish poet he
wrote over 200 poems and unfortunately
our uncle ed left the poems i have them
all i've had them bound and he wrote a
poem about his ireland i want to read
one of the stanzas of the poem he said
from the fairest land except my own
nor sun
this excuse me neither sun or star or
moon
a citadel of liberty
my mother's land arun
of course i'm not the first
irish-american descendant to
uh uh not by a long shot to be on this
in the white house
fully half of the american presidents
can claim ancestral connection to
ireland
including the man who held his job when
i was vice president barack obama
but it was john f kennedy our and his
would you stand up medicine
[Applause]
our first irish catholic president who
visited ireland in 1963 and said quote
our two nations divided by distance have
been united by history
well that's as true today as it was then
today those words feel particularly
poignant as ireland the united states
stand united in this momentous point of
history vladimir putin vladimir putin
has launched an unconscionable war
against ukraine
against the very pillars of
international sensitivity
and two nations that have fought for
freedom we recognize the current
determination of ukrainian people who
defend their liberty now
[Applause]
republic of ireland and our nation have
lived through war
we're determined though to help the
ukrainian people bring an end to putin's
brutal assault and restore peace to the
ukrainian people
as nations that have been marked by
immigrants who departed ireland and
coffin ships
and immigrants who sought the safety of
new beginnings in the united states
we are open and our hearts are open and
our arms are open to help more than 3
million ukrainian refugees have already
fled putin's onslaught
[Applause]
today
as a tashook and i affirmed uh earlier
today ireland the united states are
going to stay united
together with our partners around the
world to keep pressure on putin and to
strengthen our support for ukraine and
by the way
ireland is supporting
the
economic sanctions taking a gigantic hit
a gigantic kid
proportionately more than we had
took a hell of a lot of courage for the
t-shirk and that and the dial to stand
up and do what they did i really mean it
you know that mr bass you know what it's
like
we've also discussed how the united
states and ireland will take on all
challenges we face together
we're working together to fight cove at
19 to save lives around the world to
tackle the crime of crisis and to boost
global economic recovery and we're
working for real side by side in the
united nations security council which
they're now members of to address the
humanitarian crisis not only in ukraine
but around the world
and our nations both are deeply
committed to protecting the hard-won
gains of peace in northern ireland
the good friday agreement has been the
foundation of peace and prosperity in
northern ireland for nearly 25 years and
it cannot change
[Applause]
i have made that point and he's a friend
to
the prime minister of england and others
it cannot change
to preserve and extend those gains for
all the people in northern ireland and
the european union to make the united
kingdom
must continue to resolve challenges over
the implementation of the northern
ireland protocols
the united states stands ready to work
with all the communities of northern
ireland to ensure to ensure its
extraordinary economic potential and
ensure that it's realized
and we look forward to supporting the
next northern ireland executive after
the upcoming assembly elections which
are on their way
history has proven
that what the people of northern ireland
are leaders can accomplish when they
work together
yates wrote can i quote an irish poet
he wrote the line in one of his poems
hope
that you may understand
hope
that you may understand
because for the irish
and for all of us irish americans the
hopi is essential to understanding
and to life from our perspective
hope is what brought forth
on the emerald island the nation of
poets and patriots chains scholars
artists and engineers
hope kept us looking toward the far
horizon urges us
or urges us to over every obstacle
tells us to try again when we fall short
to rise each time we fall
our mom used to have an expression
as long as you're alive you have an
obligation to strive
and you're not dead to seeing the face
of god
and she meant it
she meant it
well my view that's the irish of it hope
is what brought us the irish american
kid
all the way from scranton to woke
scranton to the white house
with a lifetime of history of hoping
comes a deep understanding of what our
nations and our people can accomplish
hope was what brought us here
and around the same time my
great-great-grandfather owen finnegan a
shoemaker boarded a coffin ship in 1844
in the irish sea with another year
five weeks after another shoemaker named
joseph kearney from montego
arrived on another ship in america just
five weeks earlier
that was president obama's great great
grandfather they're both shoemakers not
far from one another when we were here
when i first got that the
genealogy done by the lds by the mormons
uh church that most extensive biological
archaeological
most extensive records on genealogy
getting into biology here
they said it's not sure they may see one
another but when i went over to ireland
quote with my family to to go home
to meet some of my relatives i didn't
know our relatives didn't know they
indicated the likelihood they were both
shoemakers
both not far from one another both
leaving for america five weeks apart
it is not improbable that they would
have known one another
they left everything behind
like all your relatives for an uncertain
future
but i wonder in all of their dreams
whether they could have ever dreamt
that they're two great-great-grandsons
of shoemakers from ireland will be sworn
in as presidents of the united states of
america
[Applause]
not about me
not about the rock
it's about hope think about it
but again as my grandpa would say that's
the irish of it so i want to again thank
the team for making the trip to
washington though he cannot be
positioned today
and contain a strong relationship
between our two great nations
now we have a special message
mr president and first lady senators
representatives ladies and gentlemen
as we gather this year to mark saint
patrick's day an annual occasion that
means so much to so many americans and
to irish people everywhere we do so in
the consciousness
that these are not normal times we are
reminded by the appalling events in
ukraine that freedom and democracy can
never be taken for granted
each generation must be ready to stand
up and defend them
we are reminded also
of the lengths that those who oppose
democracy are prepared to go
to stop others enjoying its benefits
in the people of ukraine we are reminded
of the boundless bravery and resolve of
those who love their country and who
value its freedom
and importantly
we are reminded of the importance
of the shared values and principles
which are the bedrock of the enduring
friendship between our countries
as we confront this crisis
i'm reminded of the words of james joyce
put into the mouth of his 20th century
every man leopold bloom in ulysses
published a century ago this year by an
american woman in paris sylvia beach
joyce wrote
force
hatred
history
all that
that's not life for men and women
insult and hatred
and everybody knows
that it's the very opposite of that
that is really life
and that is why we stand together
to ensure
that what joyce described as
perpetuating national hatred among
nations shall not prevail in our time
this ceremony has a long history
and yet it has perhaps never meant as
much to us as it does this year
and that is because
more than any other president of our
times
your family's story captures the
overlapping stories of ireland and
american the shamrock presented to you
today
recalls the lies of the bluets of county
mail and the finnegans from county loud
i took the opportunity to have the ball
inscribed especially for you in the
irish language knowing how you would
value that
your family's perilous journey across
the atlantic and those of the other
irish names that adorn your family tree
reflect the experience of the millions
of irish people who left their homeland
in the 19th century to seek better lives
for themselves
the departure of so many people from our
shores many at a very young age left a
huge gap in our society and deposited
oceans of pain in the hearts of those
that left behind
longing for departed family members they
never saw again
in more recent times
our diaspora has been an inestimable
source of strength to us in the search
and achievement of peace and political
progress in northern ireland
mr president
i salute
the immense contribution
made by the congressional friends of
ireland of which you were a founding
member back in 1981.
their efforts were instrumental in
securing indispensable american support
for the peace process that culminated in
the good friday agreement an achievement
in which i know that you and many other
americans take justifiable pride
your support mr president and that of
our friends in congress
continues to be of vital importance as
we seek to protect the good friday
agreement from the complications created
by the british decision to leave the
european union
the united states will always be an
influential source of support for the
cause of peace and reconciliation in
ireland something for which we are
deeply appreciative
mr president
your family's experience is not just
woven into the story of ireland and its
immigrants it is also an integral part
of the american story
your irish ancestors and millions of
others from ireland and around the world
strove in their lives to make america
the country it is today
their labor
in many cases
literally built america
theirs was no easy street
as the irish port evan boland once wrote
they would have thrived on our
necessities
but they survived we could not even live
their hardships
parceled in them
patients
fortitude
and all the old songs
and nothing to lose
irish americans rose to occupy prominent
positions in every walk of american life
including today in this white house
designed by an irish architect james
oben
your country was transformed into 50
years after the civil war at a time when
immigration including from ireland was
at its peak
for them and countless others like them
america became what chemischini calls
the farther shore
where the lung for tidal wave of justice
can rise up and hope and history rhyme
happy saint patrick's day and have a
great evening
[Applause]
mr ambassador you got to tell them
thank you thank you thank you folks now
we have i don't know who's going to do
the introducing but now we're going to
have entertainment uh that is all irish
and so uh
you get me to sit down
i sit down
and they're they're going to clear the
stage and as my my father said my father
our father used to have a band when he
was a kid
the saxophone of the clarinet and he
could dance and he could sing he used to
say joey i don't know where the hell you
came from you have no lip
you have two left feet you can't carry a
tune in a wheelbarrow so i'm getting
hell off the stage thank you
[Applause]
one
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
ireland's premier violinist from county
loud ireland patricia tracy
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen joining us from
ireland please welcome georgia
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
do
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
do
[Applause]
so
do
do
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
thinking about all the
me
things
even more
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
leave
this
is for africa
[Applause]
so it's so easy
[Music]
[Applause]
where's the violinist
oh there she is
so i want to say thank you to this
amazing talent i mean it was spectacular
and
so
yes they are for sure
so thank you for coming and uh now i
think we'll all go in and have some food
and drink and we need it
thank you again
congratulations you're the best
[Applause]
thank you good to see you again
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you